durance du jazz du baloche la musique
qui les font la fête depuis longtemps
ont toute l'année après le groupe
réglisse et son mets de l'huile
fatalement beau fait bouillir à son tour
la scène musicale de montpellier leur
recette pour conquérir la france mambo
et salsa you lie donc vers l inde est
agaçant donc cassé l'inde est agaçant
mais à la police parce que ce pauvre
garçon à la douleur durée puisque ce
parce que ce qu'on regarde un disque
produit sia montpellier un distributeur
national qui les a repérés sains et
fatalement b est sur la rampe de
lancement à l'image de la libre et
montpellier qui devient une des scènes
musicales les plus actifs de france les
raisons des lieux de répétition minimes
grâce à l'aide du district un réseau de
salles petites et grandes
le public jeune de cette ville
universitaire résultat on défend
aujourd'hui près de 120 v toute cette
ambiance montpelliéraine que les gens de
l'extérieur voix et découvre d'un seul
coup nous en fait on l'a vécue depuis 15
ans c'est à dire on pour nous rien n'a
changé on continue à jouer de la même
façon vous mets pas ça faisait je n'ai
pas changé c'est toujours
justement voici ceux qui ont essuyé les
plâtres oresys après dix ans de galère
leur album et vient troubler disque d'or
locomotive de montpellier certes mais
une crainte si elle devait considérer
comme un phénomène de mode c'est vrai
qu'on a tendance à nous faire passer
pour un gros pas tube de l'été alors que
nous on vit en miles toute l'année et on
est musicienne toute l'année et et on a
des choses à dire toute l'année ils se
passent pas que que du soleil du
camembert et du pastis ici bien d'autrui
ce n'est pas faire offense à montpellier
que de souligner que c'est le vent du
sud suffisent alors pour cette fête de
la musique nous vous offrons ces cartes
postales musicales seront fatalement bon